is there um with like slipknot has these
legendary live shows is there a uh a
country that just goes the hardest
dude
we have so many we bring out the the
crazy [ __ ] everybody
for real like
one of the places that people kind of
warned us about is like you know you're
gonna you're gonna be put off by their
by their you know the the solemn quiet
and
politeness was japan
and dude they chased this down the
street like he was a [ __ ] beetle
for real and they
they jumped the first night we played
dude the place was apeshit and we left
we we couldn't even stop to take our
stuff off we just ran right down and got
in this big cargo van right the fans ran
out the front came right around the club
and jumped on the van and they were
shaking it like this and we were all
like this is it
this is how we die right here this is
insane we're dying in japan and it was
but then they let us like they finally
let us go
and we all sat there and it was that
weird awkward like that was kind of rad
but we almost died moment like it was
like
yeah it was i i it's this day man we go
there and they
absolutely give it up i mean it's crazy
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats